hello and welcome I'm Chasity this is
Dave and we're celebrating the launch of
Dishonored 2 today from Bethesda thanks
to our friends from Bethesda to provide
this game for us we're going to jump
into some Dishonored 2 Gameplay the game
is out today for PC PS4 and Xbox One and
we're gonna start with corvo there are
two playable characters this time right
Dave yeah so we've got Emily caldwin in
the mix this time around so we're going
to show you the different styles of
gameplay that you can do in this game
and there's a lot that you can do here
so we're gonna check out corvo first and
we're gonna do a little high chaos and
get a little crazy with it
stab all the men's so let's Jump Right
In let me show you the game
and so we are going to be showing off
the second mission first and we're going
to take corvo around so Emily caldwin is
his daughter spoiler alert if you
haven't played the first game yes so in
the first level they show that Emily was
frozen in stone and if you play as Emily
corvo is Frozen in stone
so we're going around and we're trying
to help our family member by going on
these missions and take back what is
rightfully ours and eat some lizard
kebabs apparently and some lizard kebabs
on the way we're talking about this the
other day yesterday
the world of Dishonored food never rots
no I don't understand what they're made
of yeah so at the beginning uh she goes
into like this private room that she's
had that she used to hang out in when
she was
uh younger and
there's still fruit in there
like eat it for your health it's like uh
okay but it's this is super fun so we've
got the heart you just gotta Rune very
nice I might have are you gonna are you
going to get a power with it yeah have I
got four so if you played the first game
you'll you'll see that this is pretty
familiar but you can get powers you can
get bone charms if you equip the heart
and so he's found a rune inside that
whale's mouth and so are you going to
equip a power right now let's see what
chat wants me to equip I can afford
possession that's right Vision wind
blast or devouring swarm right now if I
got another I could do Ben time yeah so
let us know we are on Twitch and YouTube
right now if you want to shout out what
kind of power we should equip for corvo
here our buddy corvo
what are the options again so that they
can we have what you know God where is
it yeah control of a host for a short
time dark vision see some stuff
blowing people away devouring swarm lots
of rats and Ben time I can slow time
very nice
so this is Dishonored 2 and it is out
today for PS4 Xbox One and PC if you're
wondering which version we're playing
we're playing the PS4 version right now
so we're on mission number two as corvo
yeah sneaking around so look at these
bad boys over here take a look at them
give them a show so these uh these guys
are pretty messed up if you
act to yeah if if you get their
attention they will just attack you this
house is very annoying scrolling with
them as well yes so we're taking out
these hives careful you have to act very
slowly oh yeah bugs if you kill the nest
they kind of scatter yeah but it's but
they'll still attack you if you get too
close yeah so be careful with that
um we thought we'd show off this level
because we kind of it's it's the it's
early games We're Not Gonna spoil too
much and we get an opportunity to
explore karnaka a little bit which is
like I think I prefer this world to this
world Dishonored one it's got more color
to it for one
the last one was so dreary
surgery
I'm just like looting as much as I can
because we're gonna head to the black
market and get some new gear that we
need is that one alive no it's not only
the red ones are alive
so you can go to the black markets and
get all of your gear and upgrades but
you can also Rob the black market so
that's kind of what we're doing here
we're we're getting ready to rob the
black market so we have to find a key to
the back door of the black market
I got bone charm healthy appetite oh
show them how to equip the bone charm so
we've got our bone charms here
food restores more Health very nice how
many bone shops can you have at a time
you can have five at the start but you
can upgrade your your little baggie to
have up to ten and they each do there's
um there's normal bone charms which kind
of give you a small bonus and then
there's things like corrupted bone
charms which give you a big bonus but
also negatively affect you yes so one I
had was
um you do more damage but people see you
easier so it's it's cut that's kind of
like a way you can tailor your run to
like high chaos because obviously if if
you're doing more damage you want to
attack people and if you're not being
worried about being seen that's that's
something for the high chaos player yep
the small little changes that you can
make to a character but it lets you kind
of customize them a little bit more than
we've previously been able to
so over in YouTube chat we're on YouTube
and twitch right now uh we shouted out
what power should we equip for corvo uh
we've got some shout outs for possession
been time upgrade or blink
a devouring swarm
Ben taimyo from triplefly thank you
yeah we'll have to get another Rune so
we can get that we'll look into that and
get some Ben time for you guys God they
are they're awful they're just awful
destroy the hives though you get this uh
blood Amber yes get some coin cash money
for you
oh god oh no oh no everything is awful
you just have to like swing like a
madman when you're close
like if someone was staring into a
window and just saw this masked idiot
yeah
so while Dave is going around
through this awful apartment of Doom uh
let me give you some description of this
game so Dishonored 2 out today this
one's set 15 years after Dishonored one
so we're 15 years after and the Lord
region has been vanquished and the
dreaded rat plague has passed into
history and an otherworldly usurper has
seized Empress Emily caldwin's Throne
leaving the fate of the Isle hanging in
the balance so you can play as Emily or
corvo and travel beyond the legendary
streets of Dunwall to karnaka the one
stazzling coastal city that holds the
keys to restoring Emily to power armed
with the mark of the outsider and
Powerful new abilities track down your
enemies and take back what's rightfully
yours so that's what's going on in this
game we've really been enjoying it we
played it all day yesterday kind of just
trading off watching each other play the
whole fun thing about this game is that
you have two options Emily corvo and
they each have multiple play styles that
you can use
all right who are we meeting here we've
got Mindy Mindy Blanchard she's got a
little quest for us very nice similar to
the previous game you can kind of do
small side quests which help you in the
main quest in the in the area that's
what we're doing again Institute cool
can you help she's got some rad tattoos
she does I know look at those full
sleeves
we're on YouTube and twitch right now
taking your questions about Dishonored 2
this is brought To Us by our friends at
Bethesda thank you very much Bethesda
what's the story there the overseas
what's the quest so so she's looking for
a body she wants us to find a corpse for
I don't know whatever you want to do
with the course I guess but the
overseers have it because they believed
here the guy was a witch killed him as
overseas I want to do
consider it if she wants the body I
suppose we you should go get the body
for it yeah we should get that body
black market so let's take a peek inside
do you not have the key yet no the key
is hidden in the um I think is that
house that was in yes I kind of found it
accidentally yesterday I'll get the key
on my run because I know where it is but
is there an alternative way to Rob this
we can black market buy things and he
can rob us with his extortion do you
have enough money to buy what you need
um
let's see we'll see let's find out yeah
what are you doing what is happening
down here there's a dead guy is that you
what were you doing man what are you
doing that
let's run around I think there's nothing
down here right
that's so nice of you well you know I
try bullet money to help out a guy all
of life so we're playing as corvo right
now
um we'll soon see some high chaos action
but right now we're looking to get some
stuff from the black market so we've got
black markets in Dishonored too and you
can either do it the legit way like
Dave's about to do or you can rob it
like I'm going to do as Emily later on
he like you have to be really careful
that he doesn't see you though because
he loses it
all right there we go hey buddy your
face is no concern of mine don't talk
about my Facebook this is the black
market
um we've got some choices 60 so if I buy
this a lot of the regulars here so as
you see we've got
some grenades some sleep darts done
mines pistol bullets spring razors okay
I've got enough for Ben time now so if
chat wants to spend time yes I think
there was an overwhelming vote for Ben
time in the YouTube chat we're also on
Twitch if you guys want to shout out
some questions to us let's see what's
going on in the chat right now
pen time Ben time so the minute I can
only do this is what you asked for
if I upgrade I can um
pause it all together so when we run
into some people we'll use some Ben time
and demonstrate how that's done
right so we're gonna go steal this body
now yes now we're on a quest for a body
Let's uh let's equip my powers for easy
access
yeah that'll do I've got like it's the
same it's the same as the first game
when you're equipping your powers so now
we're in hostile type territory right
now
they want to throw this guy into the
world of Life
over on YouTube
Razer fangs is asking I was wondering if
Granny Rags would find a return we
haven't seen her yet right no I haven't
seen her
but we've also only played about four
missions
you got lucky son
yeah someone
I need to get that wall of light off yes
so the wall of lights are back
walls of light rather oh no
hi chaos
get him there we go
the executions way more satisfying
they're very satisfying there's some
kicks there's some swords right through
the head I want to cut someone's head
off that's
yes
after turning off the wall that will
murder me and once you cut someone's
head off we're gonna do the fun thing
where you pick the head up and throw it
at there which also looks very bad in
the standard one all the heads that you
picked up look really miniature
so if you are just tuning in this is
Dishonored 2 the sequel to Dishonored 1.
it takes place 15 years after we're
playing it on PS4 and it's out today it
is out on PC PS4 and Xbox One and we're
playing thanks to our friends from
Bethesda thank you so much we're playing
as corvo right now hi chaos corvo check
this action out
it is another bone charm in here anyone
here there should be we have to equip
the heart in order to find those bone
charms oh there is
so what's in here letter from Mindy
what's Mindy got to say
nice to have you having your back
Emmerdale oh that's nice yeah so there's
lots of notes and lots of books
throughout the game again more clues
is this the room with the safe
this is the room with the uh
a couple of runes I think this will be
enough to upgrade my slow time oh yes
this is the outsider shrines gives you a
couple runes and then he comes to have a
quick quick chat with you I've seen
it's our buddy The Outsider just
chilling out just being emo like
Spider-Man and Spider-Man three he does
it looks a bit like he's going to My
Chemical Romance concert a little bit he
looks just like oh no personal space
Power the year is 2005 where Outsider is
and all the music is emo
yeah we're on chat on YouTube and twitch
if you want to shout out to us some
comments some questions what you'd like
to see later we're going to be asking
you guys what the third type of gameplay
you'd like to see is so we're going to
start off with high chaos corvo and then
we're gonna do Emily stealth mode and
then the third option is up to you we're
gonna be here until 11 A.M Pacific time
so we've got two hours of great fun in
Dishonored 2. thanks to our friends at
Bethesda all right let's go through the
wall of light now
stab on the men's
get that corpse for whatever she wanted
it for onto which James Big Mac said his
favorite band is definitely My Chemical
Romance I mean they have some jams man
they have some jams no he's saying that
the the outsider's favorite band maybe
he's secretly outsider
I wonder what his favorite My Chemical
Romance song is
um what was the Black Parade yeah
he almost started singing can I upgrade
this slow time now so I can actually
move a decent let's see so what do we
got
relativity lasting been time relativity
lets me like like when you first get uh
so what does this let you do it lets you
move at your normal Pace when you first
use Ben time you're kind of like walking
through butter
let's get a grenade oh
boom
look at that time
I killed all the civilians and none of
the bad guys
so sorry
over on YouTube aceman said who are the
characters you can play as corvo like in
the first game and you can play as his
daughter Emily caldwin so there are two
characters that you can play as and
there are different types of gameplay so
you can play stealthy or full assault
style or mix it up sneaking and combat
combined so the game supports all these
approaches
and we're going to demonstrate all three
of those stories oh my gosh wait did you
throw a head no it's just just
decapitate the guy you're in danger man
yeah I got this you got this you got
this
ahead
let me get stop throwing me like trucker
at me
oh God
there we go
he's wearing rocks so if you take the
head and you throw away it stuns them
and then you have time to knock them out
it's a good time
back on Twitch James Big Mac is asking
so are there rats or just bugs when
you're doing High chaos
um there's rats that are still in the um
in the game but I think it's oh God the
other way
I think the um the it's the bugs and the
Rats that are affected by what you're
doing in the game now yes the more you
kill the more horrible plugs and stuff
happening oh no rip
yeah it's It's Tricky High chaos is
tricky lots of dying but we're gonna
we're gonna go back in because you're
almost through this level yeah it's not
too far you can do this yeah so are you
liking uh playing as corvo right now
Corva is what I'm most familiar with yes
uh like I played a lot of Dishonored
like way too much dishonor right so it
kind of feels like like it's it's a it's
a familiar feel but in a new world
playing or something I recognize so yeah
let's talk about the differences real
quick how does it feel playing this
compared to the first game is it very
similar do you like that it's similar um
it's it's it feels bigger yeah it's more
open
um it's also like quite smoother in a
way yeah
which is I think what it needed like it
was quite clunky yeah I got to go
over here
uh chaos
take his head throw it at his friend
we're over on YouTube and twitch if you
want to chat with us and let us know how
you'd like to see some high chaos what
would you like us to do I know there's a
way you can like jump off a building and
possess someone if you have possession
at the last second to break your fall
that's pretty cool
get out of here you you can like also
jump up and then land on someone and
kill them
this is my most important tool yeah
you're most important there it is stun
them with the head
brutal
yeah so this is high chaos corvo
and he's great fun
chop off so many things in this game
there's so many things you can shop yeah
you pick up arms pick up the hand need a
hand pick up
I don't know I killed him my bad pun he
died by your pun
there's another one yeah sweet very nice
hey pal yep
that's got to be embarrassing like being
killed by basically your friends remove
hand murdered you
[Laughter]
that is truly awful and overseer
training no they they really don't
account for that in overseer training
the corpse is in this building somewhere
yes
I can hear you oh he's the corpse is
upstairs so you can steal paintings do
you want anything in that safe I can get
it later
yes you have to read all of the things
in the room so I think it's in the other
room yeah across from you there's a note
stretches to keep you safe Restless
hands roving feet ramp and hunger Hunger
and then there should be a guidebook
there it is
so Restless three three four
no Restless hands roving feet was a
rampant hunger then I think so three
four five
and then can you open the safe there's
always goodies and money in these safes
we're over on YouTube and twitch if you
want to talk to us let us know what you
think of the game what you're looking
forward to what kind of powers you'd
like to see what kind of gameplay you'd
like to see how did I put my hand
I don't know I wanted this
it's upstairs grab his corpse
Lionel on Twitch said I like Emily
better than corvo both but her powers
seem way less cool than corvo's she's
got really unique powers we're gonna
show some of them off I'm not sure how
many runes I have in my saved we're only
early in the mission but she's got
really cool stuff like doppelganger
Domino is a really cool one and Mindy
Blanchard oh oh wait so the body is here
somewhere
yeah but we'll show you some of Emily's
Powers next hopefully or just what the
options are and I'll probably be able to
equip one because I only have I think a
couple of rooms
there's the body all right we're good
take it back to Mindy there's the body
we found it success got some darts got
some money they use the corrupt bone
charms I was telling you about yes so
there are corrupt bone charms so what
explain what the correct bone charm is
so it has a positive also a negative to
it but it means you can kind of tailor
your play style with them got it so when
taking damage your Mana is drained
before your health and so that's the
bonus yeah your Mana doesn't doesn't
regenerate yes which yeah might be good
for high chaos because I'm not using too
many Powers right now yeah I think it's
worth it let's pick up this body and
just drag it around town
bring it back to our buddy Mindy
look for Mindy I think there's one guard
down there but he might have
pieced out
okay let's go so X
air addict on Twitch is asking does this
have any aim assist since you're using a
controller yeah there is a little bit of
aim assist
um which I think I think the game
benefits from because it helps you kind
of keep the flow of the game going you
don't have to go to line up shots if if
you're taking like long shots of your
crossbow you can take more time with it
for when you're sworn by guards you just
need to turn in the pistol someone then
it just helps you if you do that and it
doesn't feel like it's cheating it's not
like overly powerful it's just strong
enough to to make you feel like a legit
assassin got it right there you go
there's your course Mindy so she just
told us that um her dudes have turned
off the electric rails
which means we can just run across the
uh run across the train track to get to
our next location
so that's a clue that she's had someone
turn off the tracks so there's the
tracks being turned off
that carriages to go through the station
and kill all the men's again kill all
them men since we took all that time to
get the uh the corpse to Mindy we just
run across the train tracks don't try
this at home don't do that ever and also
don't do it if you didn't get mini to
turn off the tracks because then you'll
just
die
I like that all these objectives have
like a little course with them that let
you just jump up if you don't want to
use powers yep because um in the in
Dishonored one there was an achievement
for not using power oh no you've been
caught High chaos High chaos
they talk a lot of smack these guys
what are you gonna do to them oh boy
did his head just explode
good time oh he's on fire that's it
looks more like he's dancing that's
painful what an awful death
take him out he just got shot by his own
bro no
where are you going
no there's a wall of light be careful
fine
oh god oh did you throw someone in the
wall or they just walk into it
[Laughter]
what a grand High chaos finish to this
level
I need the head
this isn't proper if I don't have the
head
no what are you gonna do through it yes
yes
did it just blink up and then land on
them blank up link up turn down land on
them take them out it's kind of a Cheesy
strap but it works it's a fun Strat
where'd you go got the head where'd you
go did he run
they get they get scared sometimes yeah
they have run away from me as well
could hear him panicking
I find you he knows he knows he knows he
knows his friend's head is coming for
him where are we at though yo where you
at though
I think he's run away is that wall of
light off off no it turns around
that do not go through
he was very shocked about that he was if
I can take it with me
that's my friend it's like are you gonna
take the head with you oh no maybe drop
it oh well this is the end of the level
so I guess you can't bring heads with
you my Institute you can't bring heads
to Adam our Institute there we go we
just proved that to you
we're over on Twitch and YouTube if you
want to talk to us I'm going to be
playing as Emily next
and Dave will be taking your questions
there we go lethal assault oh yeah there
you go I think on those civilians that
time though oh no
yeah can you load up my game for me
while I talk to these fine folks so if
you're just tuning in I'm Chastity this
is Dave we're playing Dishonored 2. it's
launch day we're celebrating thanks to
our friends at Bethesda and we are
showing off this game that is now out
today on PS4 PC and Xbox One we're
playing the PS4 version and there are
different ways that you can play this
game because we've got two characters
we've got corvo and Emily and we're
gonna show off different play styles for
them so we just did High chaos corvo and
now I'm gonna play some stealthy Emily
during the same level yeah yeah so we
have to deal with a little bit of
loading because we're switching players
but you can have multiple saves there
are three different campaign slots I
believe yeah so you can switch off and
so if you want to play as both
characters you can totally do that and
then you can get even more out of this
game which is a lot of fun so the
campaign can be between like 12 and 20
hours depending on your play style and
so you should dedicate at least 12 hours
if you want to play through this full
campaign and check out Emily and corvo
let's load it up so I need to yeah you
have to quit to the main menu when
you're switching over to a different
character
so playing as Emily feels like something
new like you kind of feel protective
over her from the first game you saw her
as a little kid and so she's got like
this different Suite of supernatural
abilities to corvo she's got really cool
stuff she's she's got some things like
doppelganger where she makes a copy of
herself and she has Domino where she can
take out a bunch of people at once and
instead of blank she's got uh what was
the name of it far reach and then she
can use far reach to pick things up or
even pick bodies up and yank them
towards her she can move out of the way
and just distract people it's a lot of
fun I've been having fun playing as
Emily so I'm gonna play some stealthy
Emily now we're gonna switch switch
places change you should do your chair
because it's boosted up so we don't look
you don't look this isn't gonna work so
well
that's fine
your turn
thank you very much you want to switch
your mic
so we're on YouTube and twitch right now
taking your questions so we're going to
ask you what you'd like to see us play
for the third go rounds because we're
gonna do stealth Emily right now but and
we just did High chaos corvo so what is
the third type of gameplay you'd like to
see do you want to see corvo stealthy do
you want a little mix of both because
you can just be kind of a trickster
still take people out let us know on
Twitch and YouTube and we are gonna jump
into some Emily gameplay right now
this is the same level this is the same
exact feel to it considering so Emily
just has a scarf over half of her face
and nobody really bothers her so if you
like go up to people they're like hey
good morning what's up
dipping Snipes says what about high
chaos Emily sounds difficult well yes
and no but there's a lot of powers that
Emily has which are tailored to to
killing dudes yeah so when you're around
here so people are just saying hi but if
I were to take my sword out and just
start smashing stuff that would alert
people and then they all start freaking
out and I'd start have to fight people
so
I don't want to do that so I'm going to
equip the heart get this Rune so
hopefully I can show you one of her
powers I forgot how many runes I have at
this level you should have three right
now this should give you four yeah so
we've got this Rune let's find out let's
acquire some powers and show you Emily's
power choices I have cool I have four
runes right now so Domino this can link
human targets so they die or fall
unconscious together we've got
doppelganger which summons a shade of
yourself that attracts enemies
a dark vision you're already familiar
with that I already have far reach so we
don't have to equip that Mesmerize
summon a void Spirit to enthrall humans
or hounds and Shadow walk this one's
really cool I assume a stealthier form
for a short time so in this state I can
take people out or incapacitate and one
enemy before returning to physical form
so they won't see me coming back and
take out one person I'm gonna go with
Shadow walk what do you think yeah
Shadow walk is pretty dope so I'm going
to upgrade to Shadow walk so I can show
you what that looks like later on
in the twitch chat Freddy [__] says
how similar is this game to the first
Dishonored it's it's similar it's pretty
similar so if you've played the first
one you'll feel very comfortable with
this what do you think it's um yeah if
it feels exactly like you want to
dishonor game should it's it's just sort
away because I'm playing stealthy go
ahead more of the decided you loved but
with a different spin on it it's got
some it's like a lot brighter it's it's
the environments in the world which I'm
a big fan of like that's the big biggest
change when you first look at it they're
all just so much more it's so much
brighter it seems like there's more
going on there's more stuff to do it's
it's bigger it's got more of a an open
world feel to it I agree so I'm a
massive fan of that yeah so I'm going
into the black market the thing is if
you're gonna Rob the black market which
I'm about to do you won't be able to get
any upgrades so you want to go to him
first and get whatever upgrades you need
otherwise you're just gonna take out the
suit and he won't be able to upgrade
anything for you so I'm gonna upgrade my
crossbow uh accuracy and make sure my
aim is improved and stabilized I'm going
to that when you if you rob the first
black market when you encounter another
one I found that the uh the woman behind
the camera was saying like oh I should
be careful the last of Black Market was
robbed
they don't know nothing about that I
don't know anything about that man I
don't know anything about that
so I've got some stuff I want to get
some I'm going to take out all those
hives in that crazy house of Doom so I'm
gonna get some bullets just make sure
I'm ready to take out all that
so I'm gonna get myself ready
and then I can open this door and make
it easier
I think I can come back and roll the
place no one's here cool and I've come
back and robbed the place so
we're gonna show you how to rob the
black market as well so I'm gonna be a
stealthy robber sorry
all right gonna jump into here
so always watch your step stay away from
the nest
boy games I found that you can just
slash them up but yeah if you'd like to
keep my distance yeah
because there's a chance that you can
get swarmed by them
swarm by the Swarm
and upstairs is a scary dude uh I forgot
what they're called but he looks kind of
infected or zombified somehow there's
some gross dudes in this there's some
gross dudes so these guys are not happy
with me but I'm gonna move on your face
I'm gonna move slowly
sections no you won't oh carrots I'm
sure this nasty House of potatoes and
carrots
oh it's all edible yeah I get this for
money
if you are just joining us we're playing
Dishonored 2 on launch day playing on
PS4 right now thanks to our friends at
Bethesda they let us celebrate by uh
bringing you this game this morning I've
already done my high chaos corvo through
this level we're currently doing low
chaos Emily sneaking about
um I will be very impressed if you don't
get seen like maybe that should be our
objective get through the hole oh nobody
sees you I don't know if I can do that
but I can at least try to be as stealthy
as possible I have faith in you thank
you the pressure's not on or anything no
it's fine so I've got some incendiary
darts now and those are even better for
these swarms yeah where'd they go
it's the only way to be sure they won't
come back yeah so if you take out the
hive with the incendiary bolt it looks
like they're trying trying to protect
the hive but they also don't realize
that the thing is on fire they should
probably just leave it alone yep oh why
did that Miss
the bug took the bullet for you yeah I
think I shot a bug right in the face
great
all right and then where is the key you
just let me walk right past it the key
is all the way upstairs with the crazy
dude okay so I didn't let you walk very
past it you just didn't go up I just
didn't want to hang out with the crazy
yeah so I'm just going to shoot this one
oh boy this looks scary oh they're
pissed
okay that vision is basically movement
really still
stay come on let's make me uncomfortable
it's like it's in my ear
oh yes I got my bone charm what you have
a different one this time I'm not sure
let's find out if it's like randomly
generated or it depends on if you're
like high chaos or what the character is
yep what does this bone tram do let's
find out I got ground glider slide speed
is slightly faster cool these are six
lines yeah there's some cool slides we
just slide up the stairs yesterday
physics don't matter physics don't
matter it's freaking awesome it's so
cool all right cool
so I've got that you can sure have some
six slides when you're getting stuff all
right so sorry I'm moving so slowly but
these things will sting the crap out of
me to my death if I don't don't hang out
with a boat yeah so stealth Emily takes
a little bit longer but
it's a fun time that's the trade sneak
around if you take your time take your
time yeah and more satisfying it is like
me if you run in and just die and do the
sword yeah I die yeah you might die
all right so another swarm I think I'm
out of incendiary bolts there's um there
might be some bottles of whiskey that's
flammable and when you throw those yeah
shoot this one for now
cool you're like no my hive where did it
go oh boy sorry y'all please don't I'm
walking slowly don't slowly eat the
plantains haha more pistols more pistol
bullets Festival it's very nice do I
want these nasty bananas that have been
here let's look how ripe they are yeah
beautiful make some nice banana bread
out of that'd be delicious
so there's a hole back here
so this is how you get upstairs
um there's another Hive down there I'm
Gonna Save My Bullets yeah because I
don't necessarily need to go over there
you're probably only going to use your
bullets for
um taking out hives yeah and I'm gonna
do is gonna take out that dude so I'm
gonna go back up and then there's a hole
right here
oh God I can hear the voice yeah he's
really creepy I was kind of afraid to
approach him I get scared really easily
so we have that in common then yeah I'm
just like oh no
and said yes yes okay so I'll use those
for hives but I will use bullets on this
dude and I kind of just wasted all 10
bullets on him last night I was just
like get away from me because like he
doesn't go down right away he's yeah
they're
so resilient so I'm sneaking cool it's
saving he's in this room so
let's take him out
one of my favorite things about
Dishonored one was the exploration
outside the main mission so I'm glad
they kept that in here and expand on it
as well die dude just die bugs you got
the bugs on yourself [__]
see the bugs bro is he not dead no he's
just harmless he's [__] hello
you're stung in the butt this
take out the hive he'll keep oh God all
right hold on
incendiary
I can't die here not today
Young To Die by bugs there's loads of
bugs in there as well all right uh do I
shoot this I'm asking if you just slash
that cabinet you'll you'll get mostly
yeah but all right I'll use my last
incendiary
cool did it work I hope so glass is
intact oh boy oh boy oh there's a key
there you go yeah do I just slash it
yeah it's empty cool all right
I think I just got no bugs I ain't
scared no bugs
there we go black market key all right
cool someone in the twitch chat just
asked why we're destroying these hives
so we we explored this house earlier um
basically it's it's more of the
traditional Dishonored exploration but
this house is infected by these flies
that will basically if you don't either
sneak past them or destroy the hives
they'll just assault you and drain you
of your blood but we came into this
house to get this key which will allow
us to get behind a black market and Rob
the poor bugger blind that's right
I mean I don't feel guilty about
stealing from this man it's a black
market like it's a black market he knows
what kind of line of work when you sign
up to be a black marketeer exactly so
you've got to expect this sort of thing
just in case I get into some trouble
just in case I'm trying to be stealthy
is there anything that cash register
yeah uh I it was empty when I last
checked cash money this place has been
closed for a while now they're poor in
here there's nobody working so no money
to be made flammable
oh you need to throw that Assemble
somebody yeah I'm just going to jump
over this body whoop
go out here
if you fancy living in karnaka that
place is for rent don't worry about the
bugs yeah all right
let's go down here
can't go through there so this is the
door to the black market it's it is
blocked so the way up so I'm gonna have
to use far reach
okay until Emily turned up with her
sneaky ninja Power so there's a ledge
right here that I can go to here we go
the animation for far reach I'm a big
fan of yeah me too
all right I guess this is probably
quite the drop let me why can't I
there we go thank you Safety First guys
yes Safety First don't just don't just
fall down things it's not safe for you
my name's Mindy Blanchard thanks Mindy
we talked to you last time just admiring
her tattoos all right so now we're
robbing the black market I have the key
no idea you can put him to sleep you've
got some sleep dots yeah
um oh yeah I I think I do do I no no I
don't all right so I'm gonna silently
going to take him down yeah give him a
hug that's the way I'm just gonna give
him a nice hug
so I'm gonna unlock it open it
sneaky sneaky sneaky close the door so
he doesn't know that someone opened it
and oh there's a bunch of stuff but
first things first
there you go there we go
it's time for sleep
I like the big Shop clothes myself yeah
it's like oh he's done he's got a key
so all the things that we saw before I'm
gonna take all this this is all from me
now
yep got that ruined so I can get some
stuff there's a map so just robbing the
place so you can rob these black markets
in the game this is an option like like
you mentioned before it obviously now
locks you out of using them you can't
get upgrades yeah you can get oh you can
buy all the items but the other other
service the black markets offer is is uh
upgrading your your equipment same as
the um used to be able to do in in the
son of one but now you have to actually
use market for it but since the guy is
now unconscious Cash Money upgrading
anything for you
now so that's why I went to him first to
get some upgrades and then I choked them
out put him to sleep
he'll wake up he'll be just over that
line
oh hey all right take a look around
I think this is good and I saw a bunch
of good stuff here got some bullets I
got enough bullets I find that when I'm
when I play through Dishonored one and I
did the stealth run and I'd accumulate
so many grenades and things like that
but yeah because obviously I was being
stealthy yeah did you just stayed in my
pocket the entire game oh
thank you very much sir
can't take those because I have enough
I think we're good all right let's go so
that is robbing the black market
I think oh mission is still chilling she
has no idea what just happened homegirl
Mindy's still chilling she told me about
this body she's like yo I need this body
I think it was body for me don't ask why
I need it just grab it from now this is
open she's not gonna be there as you saw
in the last playthrough she moves so
don't come back to this black market
I'm gonna equip far reach to get around
because I'm trying to be stealthy trying
to be stealthy and put my sword away I
guess
yeah I'm gonna try to be as non-lethal
as possible
we said like shout out to us in five
minutes when you're murdering everyone
inside how are our buddies and chat
doing they're pretty good there's a lot
of chat about uh stealth runs but
someone didn't do a stealth running D in
Summit one I think you've done yourself
a disservice though yeah it's a lot of
fun and that you get more out of the
game that way yeah how is this different
so far it looks the same
um obviously there's a whole new
character it's a whole new game world
it's um like I said before it's it's the
core of Dishonored that Dishonored fans
love but different spins on on different
characters different ways to play
there's so much more to explore so if
you if if after playing the standard one
you feel like you wanted more this gives
you like that by 150 percent
yep so I'm sneaking around to take down
that water light they still have those
meters that let you know
sneaky peek meters yeah it's too late
for that let you know when someone can
detect you so I'm going to sneak around
someone's asking why Always non-lethal
everyone's going on lethal what what's
your preferred way to play
I mean I I played non-lethal Dishonored
one because like if you go high chaos
and kill everyone it makes the game
tricky
are coming
sorry they don't even know exactly where
you are so you can stop it
so so far for no ghosts so far sorry
buddy I saw one guy but I'm trying to
take out this wall of light so
it's fine is anyone else up there
I think they I think they heard you oh
yeah they went up there they've
discovered the bodies they're on high
alert now
if they can wake him up
yeah we did play high chaos earlier yeah
I was pretty much killing everyone in
sight so this is giving you a taste of
of the two different play Styles between
stealthy Emily hi girls corvo you can
obviously mix a match you can be
stealthy cover if you like but it feels
more fitting to his character that he
would be the one to get all vengeful and
be like Oh not this again yeah I've had
enough now it's gonna start hacking
dudes they still up there yeah they are
still up there
like a sneaky crossbow ball maybe yeah
take them out or even just avoid them
could you just get to the wall of light
and uh yeah I'd have to
let's see
is there a way up and around the wall of
light they might be able to see me now
if I'm up here right
oh there's a guy that can see you get
behind that plant pot
okay you're good yeah if you're just
joining us we're currently playing
through uh mission 2 as stealthy Emily
thanks to our friends at this at
Bethesda for letting us celebrate
Dishonored two with you guys hope you're
enjoying it so far
okay that's that they've left their
unconscious friend
are you going down if you're quick
enough there you go
yeah
there we go
so they have wind power for the wall of
light they're very uh conscious about
the world yeah it's a normal whale oil
yeah there's still plenty of whale oil
but there's no Mission wall of light
this wall of light is low emission very
nice of them all right so now I'm gonna
go over here
taken up
taking out the wall of light
one thing I love about doing um stealth
is that you can hear like the chatter
between you guys so this is through the
wall of light is that clear yeah
did you jump on that yeah
fantastic one track one done all right
so no one has seen me no one's the wiser
the hardest way to play I think is um
stealth no powers oh my God how is that
it's brutal man like you you
underestimate how much the blink helps
you get out of a bind or prevent being
seeing so obviously you can take the
higher path but doing stealth run with
with no power you're just you're just a
dude trying to stay in the shadows which
is so difficult especially when it comes
to the levels but like quite densely
packed yeah it's not a fun time all
right so this street is awful and full
of people so this is a challenge right
here let's see what we can do
all right I'm gonna hide behind this so
I want to get over this thing but I
tried jumping over last night I just
kept getting hurt by these spikes and
you have far reach over it
negative let's see
nope yep
I got how did you let me spike it but
that sounds nice that's very not nice
gonna hide behind here and then
the YouTube track someone's asking about
the characters backgrounds so um
previously I was playing as corvo who is
returning from the first game uh he was
the royal protector for the empress
saved Emily corvo in the in the first
game Emily called one Emily golden sorry
and now he he continues to be real
protective but he's also uh her Father
which is as she says in the start of the
game a combination which has some issues
with it currently we're playing as Emily
who wants to regain her rightful title
um as empress it's been taken away by
some imposter who says that it's her
aunt but she's never seen her before
so if you play as corvo it's Emily you
need to rescue again if you play as
Emily then it's cool but you have to
rescue so
it's probably nice for him to take a
break he did he did the whole rescuing
thing 15 years ago
is there a double jump like in
Dishonored one um I've not found the
double jump yet I think with agility
right yeah I do believe it doubles your
jump I think they phrase it differently
and have you got enough rooms to maybe
get one of those let's see
let's check it I just spent some rooms I
have one Rune let's see so he there the
enhancements here we got strength there
are objects farther Vitality increase
your health and resilience
block to deflect projectiles here we go
increase your jump height and your
distance I need let's see
you need at least I need at least two
yeah so that's just just the difference
okay but then if you keep going down
that tree you'll be able to double jump
which is super helpful in the first time
so don't forget your lean when you're
playing stealth
that is the thing you can do
in the twitch chat uh someone says I'm
always responded disappointed when a
sequel is super different from the first
one I don't think this is super
different it's not like Saints Row two
to three where they just add superpowers
this is just this is just Dishonored in
a prettier place with an extra character
it's just
I keep saying it but it's just more
Dishonored but with uh with extra bits
more interesting more characters
like I don't I don't think I could ever
see a Dishonored fan being disappointed
in the sequel
so I'll finally show off some Shadow
walk for you after I
reach are there enough runes in the game
to level up all our abilities
um I've not got far enough to
confidently answer that four levels in
but in in the uh in each level there are
a lot of rooms
um I think there's like I think this one
and this level is like maybe six yeah so
it wouldn't surprise me if you can get
all the way through but it would take a
lot of exploration
the metals used to make the devices are
unusually rare the techniques if applied
by anyone punching right in the back of
the head obviously yes you'll be very
quiet because there's more people in
this place and I'm trying to be stealthy
accomplish if they took the music boxes
and perverted them how much time should
one invest in each Mission I think that
I think there's relatives your play
style to be honest
um we're investing a lot of time into
into this run because we're stealth and
that's going to take a little bit more
time if you wanted to run through the
missions and just hack those up as you
as you went or even just if you if you
fancied speedrun in the game I think
it's perfectly
um viable to do that as well I'm gonna
hide back here and use my new
Shadow walk ready
do it pop it so let's hear Shadow walk
move this dude oh Darkness smile from
good good great good good night good
night Sir horrible way to be put asleep
that guy's gonna have nightmares
should be one more dude I forgot where
he is
a Runa bone jump nearby
where's the second guy
do you know
idea I think he was at the top of the
step there's last time
I don't know because I was going chaotic
there Patrol Shadow walk around this
room
there he is
hanging out R.I.P
just kidding you're just going to sleep
sleep the new Overseer masks are really
cool
um go back into that guy's office a sec
uh-huh I think that's worshiping is the
seven scriptures of uh the ones we've
read about in the book I think in the
guy's office where you entered there's
like a display case of all the all the
overseers masks
in here just to your left
yeah look at that oh wow
so the middle one middle two are the
ones from Dishonored one and the hour
two are the new ones that's a nice
Easter egg right yeah that's a nice nod
to the previous game so you already got
stuff in the safe so I'm gonna skip that
yeah let's make sure that it is safe to
proceed
and it is all right
open it up I'm gonna be sneaky girl
again
I'm really into Shadow walk I like being
able to take out one yeah
it is very cool looking
you already played through this so I
know that they're talking to each other
right now they're just hanging out
having a chat ghost is about to come to
sleep a good good ghost this is so
spooky
so we're over on Twitch and YouTube
right now if you want to chat with us
yeah what kind of gameplay do you want
to see next so we've shown you high
chaos corvo this is stealth Emily if you
want a mixture of those then let us know
what's the Play Store you'd like
if you are just joining us we're
currently playing as stealthy Emily uh
thanks to our friends from Bethesda for
letting us make this happen and
celebrate the launch for dishonor 2 with
you guys if there is anything you would
like to see let us know in the in the
chat and we'll do our best to show it
off
[Music]
yes
like your Shadow has no pockets where
are you putting your loot yeah well I
don't think I can pickpocket him right
now wait did my shadow just pick bucket
him no it didn't okay
here we go
so far so good with the stealth mode
yeah and now that I said that I'm going
to ruin it completely
oh God [__] I meant to stealth walk it's
okay stealthy then proceeds to hit the
wall gotcha it's okay you just play it
off that you lured the guy to you it's
all right Pro Strat that was and then
you loot this guy for the key do you
think you'd play a no power play through
Dave stanza is in chat is asking about
no power playthroughs maybe Dave I'm not
I'm confident enough I did the first one
in this one it's it's a it's a lot
easier because when you first meet the
overseer it says hey do you want my Mark
again or do you just want to not have it
so you can choose to hold no power play
through but man are they tricky I'd
suggest if you're going into the game I
suggest playing it through probably like
a good additional challenge yeah but if
you play it through normally once I
think you'll get a get a feel of what
you need to do and where things are and
how to best help yourself
if you go in doing no powers I almost
again I think you're doing yourself a
disservice check this out so I've got my
corrupt bone charm it's shivering
silhouette enemies Miss more often with
range attacks but you are more visible
to enemies nah let me pass on that Chris
stealth play through I'm trying to be
stealthy so that's obviously yeah that's
the exact opposite of what I want so I'm
gonna get this body that's it the body
Mindy sent me after
should I go out here yeah I think you
could hop over the uh of the awnings
that's right do some sweet jumps sweet
sweet jumps
oh don't fall don't fall don't fall
Don't Look Down Don't Look Down
there is some guards in the next Market
though all right
so what kind of play style would you
guys like to see stealthy corvo uh High
chaos Emily we can try to find some more
uh more runes to show off some more
Powers as well I know there's a few
requests for Domino which um is super
satisfying when you nail the domino
effect oh it's so good yeah I haven't
used it yet I'm really excited to see it
oh no oh no
run everything is ruined
everything is ruined oh God if you're
just going to throw this guy into the
pit I think it should trigger a cut
scene okay that's what I'm gonna do you
got it
there we go
are they gonna run down here after I do
this I won't ask
just hanging out the background waiting
for you to get free yep yep I think you
should be right my boys to turn off the
power to the carriage rails again this
is this this little bonus mission gives
you an extra kind of point of Ingress
into the next area
he doesn't have time for games I don't
know if you've heard are they coming
down here I don't think they come down
here no I think they come down the
stairs but they won't I'd imagine
there's there's something in the game
that tells you like tells the guys don't
come down here you make your mind ruin a
quest
right outside
Shadow walk
get out of there yeah but oh [__] oh God
no no
oh no oh Mindy's out of here he's
fighting oh no he's Mindy fighting
this guy talks a lot oh boy
welp
I tried to be as stealthy as I could
Mindy you good you good girl all right
she's not even phased yeah she's just
like whatever another day there's a lot
of people asking for a high chaos Emily
oh so we could show off some other
brutal Powers I could
all right okay I'm gonna do my lean
because
I think that's the only guy that chased
you as a dude you basically landed on
the guy I landed on yeah
is that the alarm oh no it's the train
[Music]
Bandera passage like Antonio Bandera
Antonio Banderas Passage
Powers down sneaky beaky like sneaky
sneaky you don't have to shove anyone's
heads off and throw them at them this
time yeah
so I just have to make sure not to alert
all those guys at the end of this level
still makes me nervous touching the
rails like I know they're off yeah yeah
it makes me stressed out they're like oh
no they're back on
some guy just
hanging out next to the switch being
like Oh I could end this right now yeah
I was gonna run but there are guys up
there and that will alert them yeah
there is noise your footsteps will also
alert them I think there is a passive
power that allows you to have like
silent footsteps while you run very nice
so if you wanted to like be super sneaky
also quickly
all right
um
I think there was only a couple of dudes
here you might just be able to jump in
the carriage and peace out I think so
I just steal his sweet ride yes Emily
mostly apart from that for that one
moment yep
okay so do you want to do high chaos
Emily through the adamai Institute let's
see if we can I'm gonna let you I'm
gonna let you try her okay yeah for that
yeah give it a go right yeah change
I'm trying to get tangled up yes
there you go according to this menu you
were mostly
mostly stealthy mostly neutral you go
not too bad I mean I call that stealth
yeah
all right if you are just tuning in
we're playing Dishonored 2. it's launch
day our friends at Bethesda brought us
this game and we're checking it out for
you there's so many different play
Styles it's a lot of fun we just did
stealthy Emily run through through the
second mission and we did High chaos
corvo so since Emily is our new girl in
this game we're gonna keep going with
Emily through the ademar Institute and
we're gonna try High chaos Emily I'm
gonna try this is actually my first try
with it yeah luckily I robbed that shop
I robbed that black market so you have
tons of stuff to work with so
you might need a couple of runes if you
want to get a different Power if we're
doing High cast maybe I'll uh use that
bone charm that you found yeah that lets
me avoid like Matrix Dodge all those uh
you should look for a rune so you can
get another power that we can show off
to them because we've had a whole other
hour of this
yeah I'm looking forward to that yeah
let's do that okay the addamire
S no wonder this place is on an island
it's so beautiful Institute of infection
not creepy at all
we're on YouTube and twitch right now if
you want to talk to us send us your
questions let us know what power you
want us to equip to Emily next your
choices are doppelganger Domino we want
to see Domino I think because it's
really cool uh but just give us a shout
and let us know what you want to see
let's jump into this level
this is a pretty creepy level as well
this is a very creepy level look at it
oh boy that's not a place where you want
to go no wonder like there's only one
track to it yeah it's on an island Dan
said have you met the crown killer no
not yet have you I'm at the crown oh
okay I haven't yet um I won't spoil the
crown killer
[Music]
but um yes it's a very interesting
questline yeah
look at this creepy Island
don't want to hang out yep
so just so you know this game is out
today it's out on PC PS4 and Xbox One
worldwide so you can get this right now
and we're playing it right now so we can
show you all the good stuff all the good
gameplay
this game takes place 15 years after the
first Dishonored
and we are currently playing as Emily
caldwin whose Throne has been stolen by
her fake Aunt he's usurped usurped as
one would say desert
uh the campaign for this is 12 to 20
hours depending on your play style so
let us know in YouTube and on Twitch
what questions you have about the game
fish gonna fishies you can possess the
fish
oh yeah and swim through here yeah
that'd be cool that would be cool but we
don't have that capability right now
all right let's charge in here see who
Hawk asked how long you've been
streaming we've been streaming for an
hour this is the second hour We're
streaming until 11 A.M Pacific time so
we have one more hour left in our stream
to hang out and play some Dishonored
we're doing some high chaos Emily right
away get away
I want to use my invisible ass can you
get Fearless achievement
uh reminder The Fearless achiever was
not sure I think I think it was one from
the first game yeah I I didn't see it in
the end of the level
there's a there are a few similarities
yes when it comes to like what the game
rewards you with right first game like
being stealthy and yeah the same way you
uh if you murder everyone you're gonna
get more rats or more more blood bugs
Tommy H says what platform are you
currently playing on this is the PS4
version of Dishonored 2.
oh Shadow walking
but you can only take out one but it's
okay you're high chaos
oh it's so cool I love Shadow walk
goodbye
it's about to go down stab that guy in a
place that I don't feel good about
there's a guy behind me oh no
stands on YouTube asks what are your
favorite individual play styles
I like stealthy Emily a lot I am I'm a
fan of switching it up yeah I'm one of
those guys that will
make a quick save ruin everyone's game
hi chaos Emily is also fun but she
I don't know you have to be careful I
died a lot
that could just be my skill set though
not the game
I think once you invest in some Powers
Yeah once you get some Powers it's it's
pretty badass yeah
I mean with Shadow walk it does feel
like
I'm so sorry I broke that I think
invisible said use the heart to know
someone's Secrets okay when we're less
right now
we will find someone's Secrets use them
in the heart but yes you can use the
heart to listen to
someone's secrets
run
just throw a plant pot on me yeah they
just they
don't I don't know why I was sleeping
glasses no you are high chaos there's no
sleeping here
just Madness so many dudes yeah
sick pot Dodge so when you upgrade
farreach you can also use it to grab
objects and pull people I was having fun
with that last night as well just like
yanking like dead bodies towards you and
moving out of the way and having it hit
someone and
I don't know this place is full of
people this is this is a bad time
for Emily
watch out
you asked for high care assembly and you
got it
this is so chaotic
they talk a lot of smack I like that
it's usually interrupted by the the
noise of their death though
it is
so I got plenty of vials yeah I was
nervous the idea yeah got hurt a lot
though so fun fact a lot of players were
asking the Developers for more
non-lethal more stealth so they
implemented that into the game so for
almost all the combat moves they've
added non-lethal versions so like combat
choke drop attacks right slide take down
Etc uh there's non-lethal versions of
those you can play the entire game
without killing which is pretty rad
there's one guy left but it's very hard
to do got him it is nice that wall of
light in the Dishonored first decision
yeah if you got into combat you
basically just had to kill the dude but
in this you can counter and choke him
out in the middle of a sword fight
so it's it's nice to not be punished
quite as much when you just have these
things yeah
so there's usually dudes here but I
think they ran down that way and and
came to join the fight yeah
you didn't eat that yeah hell yeah is
that a is that a rabbit
why can't you surround it it looked like
a fish with legs it does look like a
fish with legs it's gross
I've got my whiskey and so I need yep
that is all you need
so when you start the campaign on one
save you can only choose one player you
can't switch off
so you can dedicate one save slot for
Emily in one for corvo if you want to
change it up but you could always always
just like play all the way through with
this one character yikes I hate those
things I don't know why those bugs are
trapped in this case I don't know why
would they keep them there I already
tried to set them free
so we need to go to a hypatious office
yes we do
so once you've completed completed first
playthrough you should definitely replay
the game with the other character if
you're starting with Emily you should
try corvo let's try different powers try
a different approach and then that way
you can see how the game is experienced
at both of them and but that's the
advises to set aside about 20 hours to
get a good feel for both and during the
second playthrough you'll know more
about the world and discover new areas
as well
this is high chaos Emily and she is
going to town the whole map is after
for reasons I love let me just carry
heads and bring them around with us it's
a good time cool
what else is hanging out in here Momo
said Kill Them All I mean I'm gonna try
we're trying we're trying
Jaguar said brutal game LOL yep that's
what high chaos is all about
it's a good time
The Outsider said low chaos corvo is the
best yeah that sounds like a good time
he's got a lot of cool powers
where do I need to go now
operation down the floor down the stairs
you know keep in shape
we're on YouTube and twitch if you want
to talk to us let us know what you think
of the game what kind of powers you'd
like to see for corvo we might try to
look for a rune so we can get him one
more power before this stream is over I
mean this is Emily actually
what cool Power do you want Emily to get
she's got doppelganger where she can
make a copy of herself Domino where she
can take out a bunch of people at once
oh
I ditched the head for a leg
actually let's uh let's see whether our
hearts hanging out yeah let's see we
need we need a rune
some down there I know how to get one
okay actually that's uh let's do that
now yeah let's get that ruined so we can
equip a power for our friend Emily
caldwin
so if memory serves I can
push this button yeah
at the top
Artemis is saying is this game worth
getting if you're a fan of Dishonored
one absolutely this is even better it's
it's so much fun if you had a good time
with it you're gonna have a good time
with this uh if you haven't played
Dishonored one it's not hard to get into
Dishonored too I would say what do you
think Dave yeah I agree yeah it's um it
kind of gives you a good reason what the
story is from Dishonored one there's a
tutorial mode yeah it's it's you
definitely don't need to play Dishonored
one to to appreciate this yes I agree um
I would still recommend playing designer
Bronx it's fantastic
so yes we recommend it right scoopster J
over on YouTube is asking who's been
better Emily or corvo
that's a hard question yeah that's so
different they're so different there's
so many different play styles that it's
really difficult
um I'm having a lot of fun with Emily I
haven't played much corvo and Dishonored
2 yet so I it's hard for me to compare
oh I do want to read the note I want the
maroon but it's very refreshing to play
with her and it's cool to see her new
powers so I'm really digging Emily
personally is a big fan of Dishonored
one I I wanted more corvo because he was
so much fun the first one so it's it's
kind of nice to to have the same cover
we're familiar with but also have
um Emily is a bit of like a new flavor
oh no didn't mean to do that
oh where are we we um I've ruined the
list
stairs forever because we we broke the
elevator we're gonna have like
incredible calves though
there we go get get in the get in the
hatchet do your thing
Caribbean sky over on Twitch can you
pick up glass objects and throw them at
enemies to stun yes you you I don't know
if it stuns it's usually used more for
distraction
um if you if you're in the middle of a
com of a fight and you throw something
at someone and it hits them they will
like back yeah they'll backstab yeah so
yes in a way yeah it gives you kind of
like a small window of opportunity to
land a blow yeah there's a lot of cool
things for distraction in this game so
you can pick up glass objects and throw
them as a way of distraction I will show
it off now let's let's do it see okay so
it makes them step back yeah so yeah it
breaks their guard yeah
so if you do find any just you know
random bits and Bobs you can
there's that slide I didn't even notice
me he's so oblivious he's just into
cutting that wood
good night sir
I'm gonna kill him yeah
so this game also has alarm clocks that
you can set off to distract people so
there will be alarms in the rooms and
you can just set them and then run away
and then people will be a bit distracted
and run to that room so that's another
thing you do as a trickster
yeah there's a lot of opportunity for
kind of cool combinations yeah of sneaky
items and Powers
[Music]
right let's grab the heart again how
many runes do I have let's find out
Powers you have two two runes so what
are you shooting for
um maybe Dr Banger doppelganger or
Domino even I think one of those two
would be really cool to show off let's
do that there's there's one up there and
there's one over here
so I can oh there's one down here as
well
okay so that's one yep
I just need to get another one down just
need one more rune
is that
the farage is so satisfying so
satisfying
where is the other room
I just lit it all over the place I'm
surprised that like not everyone in the
world of sun it has power is considering
there's like 80 runes
uh no bugs nobody knows over on YouTube
said I chose corvo for my first
playthrough because I love his powers
but I'm 100 going to go with Emily the
second time yeah you should try both you
have to see all that this game offers
and if you are a fan of Dishonored you
have to try Emily yeah sure I know
they're both so different and offer such
different play Styles it's basically
like playing two games
honestly there's more bugs in here than
last place it's awful I hate the bugs
I don't know if it's because I'm wearing
headphones or sounds of them it's it's
like they're in my ears they are in your
ears
I'm so sorry let's check if this goes
yeah he's definitely dead he's a Twist
he's definitely oh yeah you're Savage
Savage Emily
no do you have an incendiary Dart you
can just Light It Up
there you go and some rum light this
room up
get lit it's lit
damn it I missed oh no
[Music]
throw them all to have rum bottles says
dragon ninja
do we have any I just threw them out the
um
yeah of course I get spray for the bugs
LOL
if only
bug spray Rory the sloth one asks so far
how long would you say the game is it
totally depends on your play style
it takes a lot longer if you're playing
stealthy but it's totally worth it I
think about the quickest your campaign
can be is about 12 hours is what you
look forward to people um when this game
comes out speed running this and just
breaking it in half yep
we're over on YouTube and twitch taking
your questions
comments what are you excited about what
do you like about this game and
what powers would you like to see
Emily equipped with
healthy appetite that's the one for food
right I believe so food restores more
Health very nice shivering silhouette as
well whatever it is cursed yeah let's
find out it's got good and bad to it
Dominoes grab Domino yes we can get
Domino we we're gonna show off Domino
for you so this one links human targets
together and takes them out
should be pretty fun to watch all right
I'm out here it's gross
freak me out
and grab this health first though
because I got into hell get that hell
getting stung by all those is not fun it
gets very scary I usually just start
flinging my sword around aimlessly and
spinning in a circle when those things
come at me I mean it's pretty solid
strategy
which is what I would do in real life I
feel like I would just start swinging my
sword around and screaming and spinning
in a circle whatever works right yeah
ouch
it's a bad time
I jump on that
trying to conserve my energy
no I think he wants me to go through the
door to trigger this
over on YouTube he's out Offman said is
this on the PS4 yes this is the PS4
version but you can also get it for Xbox
One and PC today
it is out today we're launched we it's
we're celebrating the launch right now
thanks to our friends at Bethesda and
that is why we are live streaming all
the way for another 45 minutes
checking out all the different types of
gameplay I'm eating this bread eat this
nasty bread
so we need to go talk to this woman but
I want to show off
like what's going on here
what is that like what are we looking at
this isn't a desk whenever anyone should
have yeah what kind of Weird Science is
happening in this room
that's gross some real nasty science so
um
spoilers for the uh first spoiler alert
first main mission but we're about to
talk to this woman and we're gonna find
out a bit more about her character yeah
let's find out let's learn about it
sorry
I I should know that yeah you should you
should know that something
that's my face you were just dissecting
a rat don't touch me
anyone likes to admit I'm not here for
treatment I'm looking for Anton's Circle
we're looking for that doctor yeah
remember so glad from the first game
he's just gonna get so mad at you he'll
be like please stop kidnapping me that's
what you do what do you want don't use
the rats again please
came from the new
so a little bit of backstory if you've
if you've missed some um the crown
killer
we were introduced to at this very start
of the game it was someone who was
taking out uh Emily's enemies so when
Emily was usurped the interloper
basically used that as an excuse to said
okay you're obviously the ground killer
you're taking out all these guys that
you hate
um it's the big not only is this has a
throne been stolen she's also Being
Framed for excuse me dozen murders
yep so that Crown killer is just making
us look bad
so here comes the spoiler
[Music]
Vasco yikes
yikes sad shape it's not in a bad way
good way definitely in a bad way this
poor dude are you all doesn't even have
a blanket Dr alopecia did this
she's the crown killer oh but she's not
herself
trying to help the miners
the first version caused
horrible sorry for the spoilers guys
you were alerted
this is mission three of Dishonored two
and if you're just tuning in I'm Jesse
this is Dave we're playing through
Dishonored 2. we're here for another 45
minutes checking out the new game it is
out today worldwide on PC PS4 and Xbox
One and we're talking to this poor poor
man we're playing as Emily right now hi
chaos Emily so we already did High chaos
corvo we did stealthy Emily and now we
are playing uh oh we're in trouble
it's the Mad Doctor
so she's been being poisoned
and like like he said she's the crown
killer but it's it's the poison that's
affecting her mind and making her kill
yep
um similar in previous games that you
can take people out in in uh different
ways you can spare them and help them or
you can just murder them if if we wanted
to keep her alive we could make the
serum that this guy was talking to us
about
um but since we're High chaos we're
gonna try and yes we are take her out I
hate the smell in here
Toby asked who are they playing as right
now we're playing as Emily High chaos
Emily to be specific
I'm gonna be sneaky until I find her
after she turns she kind of just wanders
through the level um
and bugs X-Men on YouTube said like
Jekyll and Hyde yeah pretty much pretty
much that's what's going on with this
poor doctor
Danza asks what are your thoughts on
crafted bone charms I haven't tried it
in Dishonored 2 yet that crafted bone
charms would be interesting but
there's like
a dozen in each level so you'll probably
have a fair amount you can work with
either way where is she
heard her but now she is silent
we're looking for the Mad Doctor
the serum has made her crazy mounted her
brain it's melted her poor poor brain
for some backstory Dishonored 2 is set
15 years after the first game and now
you can play as Emily who's all grown up
now and she is kicking some butt
it has to deal with all these hives oof
don't sting me
there are different play Styles in this
game so we're playing High chaos right
now but you can also play stealthy or
you can mix it up sneaking and combat so
it really is whatever you want it to be
there's so many different options
uh oh
Shadow walking I love Shadow walk
get her get her yes
Target assassinated place for Monsters
like you and Maya we got the crown
killer guys
gross looking never dead one for One S
are you both playing I played uh
stealthy Emily so we're trading off yeah
yeah so he's playing High chaos Emily
and this is first go-round with Emily
how do you like it I'm really enjoying
it so far
um
it does feel like she like she needs to
be a little more careful when it comes
to Mobility I feel like blink it might
be a little bit more powerful just
because you can kind of blink anywhere
rather than that's the entire to like
actually finding something to grab onto
see if we can find a couple of dudes to
Domino
yeah we should Domino
we have to demonstrate Domino for them
Okay so we've got two dudes here he's
losing it yelling nonsense for hours
could you understand
something about being attacked them take
them out like a domino
so they're gonna
take one out the other one gets taken
out that's so cool pretty rad that's
gonna look really cool when we do it
with like four people I think there's um
a way to upgrade Domino where you get
more more people
because I think in the um in the demo
that was shown when someone's first
announced it's like four four guys one
got hit oh these hives are awful
we're over on YouTube and twitch if you
want to chat with us hang out with us we
are here for about another 40 minutes
playing through Dishonored 2 thanks to
our friends at Bethesda
this is the PS4 version that you're
looking at right now
we're playing as Emily High chaos
oh hello friend are you okay
I don't think he's having a good time he
doesn't seem to want my help either
I'm sorry bro
he's going crazy you think he's had a
little bit of that serum Maybe
I need to go to or maybe just working at
this awful Place yeah it's not I think
it'll drive you crazy yeah it just looks
like everyone's gonna go nuts
oh yikes
I love that slide so good when you
landed attack
oh no is it too late to Domino
just have to be sneaky in yeah lose
sight of him
I should maybe we can kite another guy
if there's someone else down here see
how many people we can dominate yeah we
want to Domino a bunch of people show
that off
Megan can pick me up they're still
chasing me oh there is it oh no
Spotlight on me oh no Spotlight do you
wanna
far reach yeah
oh gosh yeah throw that you throw it
yeah that's done
that's done I think they lost sight of
me as well
they all that though
that guy died I think he just fell off
I think there's only two people here
that I can see yep you can dominate
these two though
um can I reach up there
yes you can nice Far East is so useful
to range to Domino these guys yeah
yeah how many guys are there Just the
Two by the looks so we're trying to
demonstrate Domino but we want to get a
bunch of dudes so that we can take them
all out at the same time
together Emily's cool powers that you
can equip you can also equip
doppelganger which makes a copy of her
and when you upgrade doppelganger it'll
attack for you which is really cool now
both of these guys should be rip yeah so
you took him out so the other one should
be
dunzo
he is so dead
I need the head though
[Laughter]
it's kind of our thing just picking up
heads maybe Magnum Foster wants it
I got this head can we take it with us
she didn't even Flinch okay this needs
to come back with me
ready now she doesn't like this place
either
back the Dreadful whale don't forget my
luck let's go
oh I found in the seat
that was our keepsake
no there was no circle of here sorry she
was the crown
kicked her into
jail
it is possible to save her like I said
you have to develop a serum
yeah that makes it more of a challenge
to do this whole thing without killing
everyone but it is possible though yeah
so they developed it in a way that you
can play this entire game without
killing anybody so am I trying to try
that let's play through yeah try that it
sounds really difficult though invest a
lot of money in sleep dots yes
be very very sneaky and sneak up on
people I saw a boat you can Sleepwalk on
people and then
and then just like take them out yeah
knock them out yeah yeah all the way
lethal all the way lethal all right what
do you guys want to see let's switch
back to corvo let's have you switch back
to corvo okay
um and I think there was a request for
stealthy corvo we could do stuff all
right all right let's do some stealthy
corvo
so if you are just tuning in this is
Dishonored 2 I'm Chastity this is Dave
we're showing you the different play
styles of Dishonored 2 brought to you by
our friends at Bethesda and this is
launch day so we're celebrating the game
is out worldwide on PC PS4 and Xbox One
so we already saw how we play with high
chaos corvo we did stealthy Emily and we
just did High chaos Emily so now we're
gonna try stealthy corvo the best we can
I'm gonna let you try because I haven't
played corvo yet and I'm just gonna hang
out with my buds here on Twitch and
YouTube so if you have any questions if
you want to see any powers equipped to
corvo while we're still here let us know
what you want to see corvo do because
we're gonna do some stealthy corvo
action
the last save
the good doctor
this one yeah
the same Mission again but we'll be
stealthing our way through yes ooh and
you saw all those people that the entire
map pretty much attacked Emily so every
dude now we have to try to do that
stealingly without being seen about
maybe I'll just run away I don't think I
would be able to do it I would fail so
I'm just gonna let Dave Take the Wheel
on corvo because I've only been playing
Emily so far
I think it's um
the variance between the two characters
though as we saw with Emily she
she's very good at stuff but she is a
lot of her abilities are
very useful when it comes to killing
dudes as well
whereas corvo he pretty much just has to
stay in the shadows like he doesn't have
a shadow walk that you can sculpt past
people with but then again his blink is
much more useful to get to it is as well
so I agree
over on YouTube we have our ruin who
said did it start recently we started
about an hour and a half ago at 9 00 a.m
Pacific time we are going for another
half hour and right now we're gonna try
this same mission Mission 3 as stealthy
corvo mm-hmm
as requested by someone in YouTube chat
sorry I forgot who asked
possession would be really useful maybe
I should try and get possession
yep there's a rune over there this is
the PS4 version that you're looking at
by the way
there is a bone charm under wrestler yes
pretty sure I just die if I go down here
um do you have
link
oh yeah just land on that pipe go down
to that and then look right there oh
sorry sits in the boat
give me debt exact thing let's see let's
see what we got
crossbow bolts it fits slightly more
slightly more damage cool let's equip it
so we're gonna go for no kills or uh
let's just do stealthy maybe this will
be like a mix like first piece of rotten
fruit I've seen inside ew don't eat it
yeah even the the food in that nasty
chamber full of hives that was fresh
enough to eat that was fine this one is
not
okay let's uh where's my blink at here
we go yeah let's make this one a mixture
you don't have to you can be stealthy
but you can still take people out okay
yeah
we haven't quite done that yet
let's do a mixture of it
Muhammad Hussein said is it PS4 or PS4
Pro this is the PS4 version not the pro
version that you're looking at
oh I've been seen already oh no
sorry there's so much for that
run away run away it's okay no alarms
though oh no you hurt yourself but yeah
you have to time that just right
it's very tricky
that's right we can restart yeah we'll
restart it's okay and this time we have
another chance to go stealthily I'm not
gonna see yeah I was sitting in high
chaos there's a lot of people in this
level so it's gonna be really hard to do
it stealthy so for sure
we are on Twitch and YouTube right now
chatting with you tell us what you like
about the game tell us what kind of
powers you'd like to see corvo with
we're gonna try to find another Rune so
we can equip another cool power and show
that off before the end of this stream
we're streaming for another 30 minutes
talking about Dishonored 2 brought To Us
by our friends at Bethesda
engage sneak mode now sneaky sneaky
hey buddy oh hello
Nicholas endosa could you guys try the
stealth way yep that's what we're trying
we uh we got caught but we're doing it
stealthily now hopefully we'll do our
best for you we'll do our best for you
oh
I think I'm still okay yeah so this is
stealth but still still fighting so
we're doing we're mixing up nobody
the gameplay right now that's pretty
cool actually saw me so I threw him as a
friend at him that was good
it's okay all right we're still yeah
still shadowy give me those grapes
yeah so right now we're trying a kind of
place now where we're sneaking but still
using combat so mixing up stealth and
lethal but not high chaos this is where
I got sore last time so I'm just gonna
scope my way past here yeah so this is
another approach that you can do when
playing so you saw us full High chaos
this is a little less where you're
sneaking around
which is kind of a good way to go yeah
I'd say I've got eight crossbow balls
mixes up mixes up the play styles for
you while you're going through the
campaign
so when you do go through the campaign
you only go through it as one character
unless you save it to another campaign
slot so you have to play the entire
campaign as one character you can't
switch off at every Mission the other
character gets frozen in stone uh at the
beginning of your campaign so you can't
play as them
but you can switch to a different save
and try it out as the opposite character
no alarms we're still good yeah yeah
we're still good no alarms have been set
so we're still fairly stealthy
it's this weird fish with legs looking
thing again yep weird rabbit fish legs
for dinner
delicious yeah
talk to us on Twitch and YouTube let us
know what power you'd like to equip on
good old buddy corvo over here
at the minute I think um
what are we gonna use what was someone
in that left possession Maybe
oh possession is a good one and you can
possess animals some rats some fish
I missed him oh no
so if you didn't hear before there are
two playable characters corvo and Emily
and that's what makes this game a little
bit different there's a lot of different
play Styles and this game is set 15
years after the first one
they saw me but I managed to escape and
I'm gonna follow me down into there
we're trying to be as sneaky as possible
it's very hard I love this picture of
circle off yeah I do too it's in
subtractive light I'm Gonna Take It Well
it it's lit sorry uh you're not sorry no
okay okay do we know what power we want
yeah all right anyone voting for powers
for corvo speak up now or forever hold
your peace get out of here
let us know what power you want tell
them their choices so we have possession
yeah possession uh dark vision wind
blast and devouring swarm cool Christian
the First on YouTube is voting for
possession he's the first one to speak
up so he gets possessions
power up yes please thank you very much
thank you Christian
we are getting possession for you
just in the nick of time maybe
as well oh
yeah
X-Men also wanted possession so yep
there you go they're never gonna catch
me I'm too sneak
in the bathroom
do you already have bedtime you do right
uh yes yeah yeah Jerry asked for bedtime
we have that already and we we can show
you a little bit of that too so let's
make be sure to show them some bedtime
and some possession
since we just got possession let's let's
try that out
do I need to not be seen by this guy I
think I need I think you need to not be
seen I just get out of here so we can
reset the stealth then wait you run to
or Run YouTube over on Twitch was there
was a request for possession and blink
we have both of those now so get ready
for fun we will
hey give me yeah possession is super
useful I agree with you ax man oh I'm
out of I'm out of juice oh no he's out
of juice
is that cursed bone charm that I put on
probably let's let's unequip that
I'll be able to find some
juice
I really like the world in this uh it's
very
like it's it's not completely open world
but it's it's very it's very open for
exploring and it's kind of like a
character in its own right it's there's
a lot of story there there's a lot of
architecture a lot of weird characters
around there
um
it's also punctuated by like a lot of
cool Mission locations
so they made quite the cool world here
for us in Dishonored too I needed the
head
always need the head
pick it up there we go
so if you missed this earlier we were
throwing heads at people to stun them
it's a strong strategy it is a great
strategy it's a good time
you didn't see nothing rocket in space
over on Twitch asked does corvo start
with the previous game's maxed Powers no
you have to equip them again you have to
get all the runes again and get
start over
yeah for example
um yeah I don't I think uh the last
Hokage over on Twitch says you can't
possess humans until you upgrade it I
think I think he's right yeah yeah
he or she
you can possess a sweet fish though
we can possess a fish that's true we can
go to the Fountain because there's a
fish
ax man said bedtime is better than
possession but not as fast
maybe there's a way to the office using
uh using a rodent
so we now have possession with we're
playing as corvo a mixture of stealth
and and lethal
and we have possession we have
uh what other Whip and time and blink of
course
oh God hello I need the head again so
slow this guy has had an awful time
laughs
that was really funny in slow motion
maybe there is there's gonna be some
rats around here somewhere give me some
more potion give me some Mo I wonder if
you can possess the bugs axeman asks we
haven't tried it I don't know if you can
let's read the power thing yeah
let's tell us more possession
a suit control of a host for a short
time this is chain hosts corpse position
oh God I didn't know that was a thing
human possession there you go you need
to upgrade it quite a lot for uh oh yeah
definitely need an upgrade for that
that's why we couldn't do it so small
animals such as a fish or rat so it
doesn't look like you can possess bugs
no wait you can't possess bugs I saw
that in a demo I'm sure I saw it I said
was it probably bump into some bugs now
there they are
head shoot with a head Mizuki bug now
you're a bug I'm a bug oh my gosh bugs
but don't bother bugs there you go X-Man
we're a bug we're a possessed blood fly
nailed it that was that was the best run
through that room because I did that was
cool yeah that was great
fantastic so yes you can possess so
shall we go for the way uh saving her
this time yeah let's see if we can do
that that sounds like the harder way to
do it so since we've already killed her
let's try to cure the good doctor
get good doctor back
great paintings over on YouTube
Lars is asking which is better and
faster blink or far reach I think blink
right uh I think what you were saying
yeah I think blink is more versatile
because you don't need to have like an
objects to actually attach to the
abilities whereas far reach you have to
actually be grabbing onto something
physical then again far reach can
actually bring things to you so
prefer strictly Mobility reasons I think
uh blink is better but for
um different uses you can probably get
more at far reach
I didn't mean to turn the tap on I'm
gonna waste water
head is still there I mean I can't
complain about you know throwing heads
around yeah too much we actually got a
shout out about that on Twitch fshavin
said enjoying seeing heads being chucked
about like a dodgeball
[Laughter]
it's all for you guys dialogue this time
I'm having a lot of fun
I need this
give it
also yeah or talk to this guy
another fun fact about this game
Dishonored 2 is brought to life with the
new void engine Elite forward and
rendering technology built from iD Tech
and highly custom customized by Arcane
Studios so there's another fun fact for
you
designed to support world-class art
Direction and take full advantage of the
powerful Hardware the generation has to
offer
the void engine allows for significant
advances to all game systems including
responsive stealth and combat artificial
intelligence lighting and graphical
rendering impressive dense Urban
environments and story presentation
yeah this game looks great it really
does yeah
thank you Arcane Studios can I possess
another bug so I can avoid this yeah
massive room again yeah let's get out of
this nasty room using possession
like the Bumblebees I'm out of here
I'm gonna steal these though
yep take that
I want to read you a note no don't read
your note don't read your note it takes
time
foreign
so if you join us later or just joining
us now we have 20 minutes left in the
Stream this is our celebratory launch
day stream of Dishonored 2 brought To Us
by our friends at Bethesda we are
playing on the PS4 I'm Chasity this is
Dave we are doing a little run through
mixing up the play style we already did
High chaos corvo we did stealth Emily we
did High chaos Emily and now we're
mixing it up doing stealthy but lethal
corvo yeah it's a mixture of a mixture
everything all the good stuff
and the game is out today worldwide PC
Xbox
PS4 we're playing on PS4
and we highly recommend doing the
campaign as both corbo and Emily you get
more out of the game that way more play
Styles more powers
try it all out it's worth it you can
invest about 12 to 20 hours into this
game is recommended
to try all of the things what did he say
the code was I don't remember I wasn't
looking at your screen I'm sorry I'm
hanging out with my buddies over on
YouTube and twitch I'm seeing what
they're up to
show history
Kayla Beach said what how long is the
stream going to be we're going for 18
more minutes 18 minutes on the clock
yes that's what I want 18 minutes to
complete this Mission 488 thank you very
much very nice very nice
so we have to make an Elixir to
write the doctor's brain
that the key
uh grind all the ingredients add some
egg whites what is this a is this for a
serum or a cocktail we're trying to cure
the good doctor here we killed her in
the last playthrough as high KS Emily
but we're trying to cure her now
similar to just uh Dishonored one yeah
there's always a lethal and a non-lethal
way to take down your targets just gotta
shut that so
syringe Orion is asking what's better
corvo or Emily and stealth or kill kill
kill I prefer stealth
um when it comes to characters though
they're both they're both very different
and they both offer different advantages
and disadvantages yep
um the best way like we've said before
is to play there's both of the guys yep
I think you're gonna get most out of
your of your game absolutely if you've
already played Dishonored one I'd say
start with Emily change it up see what
she's like see what she's about
I agree and then and then replay as
corvo yep something you're similar with
if you've never played Dishonored before
I'd probably say start with corvo or
then go to Emily yeah see what he's
about he's gonna go by decided one and
play it there he's the OG play with
corvo first if you've never played a
Dishonored and you can definitely jump
into Dishonored 2 without having played
Dishonored one so don't worry about that
they're both fantastic games though so
if you want to get a little backstory go
ahead and check out that Dishonored
Definitive Edition and then jump into
Dishonored 2.
both great games doing some chemistry
we're doing chemistry right now we're
trying to cure the good doctor
we're trying to take care of her in the
non-lethal way in this playthrough
because we killed her in the last
playthrough of this mission
this is a nasty looking syringe it is
that we need I need to inject this into
the good doctor
this room should be clear that slide is
so satisfying
I've got to go through the bug room
again oh no the dreaded bug room so I
burned a bunch of them yep
is the more room yeah so as you've been
watching this stream let us know on
Twitter Youtube which playthrough did
you like the most did you like watching
stealth Emily did you like watching the
fun high chaos oh no we died my bug died
I mean I died we died as a bug
oh no God wait bugs
that's right we've got plenty of time to
find yeah we do uh what ending did you
get in Dishonored one Dave uh I got this
Godly Destroyer the um low chaos ending
okay I'll send it well I got both I've
played through the game twice but um the
first one yeah I always felt like that
was the ending that I always wanted to
aim for didn't kill anyone
um I didn't not get a scene though I
kept everyone alive did all the good
stuff nice and then because that that
that
um dictates what kind of empress she is
right like
yeah
so in my world she's a she's a lovely
nice Empress so when I play as well when
I when I play as um as Emily I will be
playing her as the empress that um
Corvette helped influence yes so low
chaos not killing anything low chaos
when I pass corvo I'm gonna stab all the
men stab all the boys armor right now
that's what no I was aiming for X-Men
says it was Dishonored one DLC
irrelevant
um
I don't know how much how much is
relevant to the story it is great though
um Dowd is one of the coolest characters
and fighting the Brightmoor witches was
super fun
um it probably gave you more insight
into kind of the sorcery element of the
game when it comes to uh the
brightmobile witch DLC
but I think that's the only relevance
that you you need really yep
all right get behind it I'm still a bug
neojet angel said hi chaos I guess you
know jet Angel liked our high chaos
playthroughs the best
well those were the funniest ones
it's throwing yeah
oh we're curing you
gotta make you good again you're right
doc
you're fine you got a massive syringe in
his spine but that was a huge syringe
trying right
sorry are you okay I don't know how much
she remembers about all the do you
remember yeah do you remember being
actually a murderer someone
if you need a place to lay low for a few
days come find us I reckon we've got
enough time to to end this Mission yeah
we do have time to end this Mission we
have 13 minutes on the clock till the
end of this stream which is brought To
Us by our friends at Bethesda this is
Dishonored 2 on the PS4
maybe the pick-me-up yeah
I always do with a pick-me-up
oh what's his name though Vasco
Yee
oh there's the bug that I was
back exit that's where we need to go
Margarita on Twitch said hey Dave
hey you're one of my top three flavors
of pizza
[Laughter]
that's a good topic
out of here back exit
what's going on on YouTube uh we are
playing Dishonored 2 is what's going on
we're only playing for about 12 more
minutes but you will be able to see this
whole stream on YouTube on gamespot's
YouTube after the fact we showed you the
different play Styles in this game
we had high chaos corvo we had stealthy
Emily
and we had high chaos Emily and now
we're doing a mixture of
stealth and lethal foreign
we want to hear someone's secrets that
was a request earlier
oh it's so cryptic
oh
no oh talking about Groove
every time a head comes off you know I'm
going to
don't you run don't you run don't you
run
I'm still gonna throw the heady
here we come ah if that if that landed
where'd it go there it is
got the head that's kind of our theme
for this stream today is how many heads
can we pick up and throw around attack
people with that guy's out of here
it might work though
excuse me sir Kingdom May said May
before you end the stream jump off to
the Sea
but I tried so hard I got so far but in
the end it doesn't even matter
oh the guy did die I threw the head of
the guy fell off by somehow
blinking around blinking around taking
people out put him in the sea you don't
even need to stab dude sometimes
sometimes you just slide into their
shins yep sliding into The Shins picking
up heads throwing them at your friends
take them all out jump on their heads
take them out and stab them in the back
come on do you want this whale oil
Kobe
oh I got him he got him that carried
okay you're dead is he dead he's
definitely dead he's got a concussion
it's pretty dangerous I shouldn't sleep
when you've got a concussion Oh my days
oh my word who did that who has done
this to us I don't deserve this
I'm a nice man
all right there's a whole kitchen yeah
it's a full kitchen we got a weird
rabbit chicken fish
hope not it's gross a bunch of people
were screaming jump on YouTube I guess
into the sea too too late sorry
well I suppose if that's what the
comments want what
there you go rescuer
delicious
gross
phew
why why is why is this a thing
all of the things that's it please
I don't know where I don't know if
there's another guy alive yeah wait
maybe we have about nine minutes left
shout out to us on YouTube and twitch
tell us what you like about the game
tell us which run through you liked uh
tell us what you're excited about about
this game tell us what you think of me
and Dave but be nice
oh yes we threw the fish I've become the
fish
look at this can I just shout out how
creepy this fish head looks yep they did
a good job designing that fish
what happened man I don't know it feels
like someone to throw a fish head in my
bag this is so funny
Kingdom they said so gross how did those
Tails still move I don't know
yeah oh God it's the nerves that are
left in the fish
oh my gosh I'm I'm not killing anyone
unless I use a fish yeah eight minutes
to finish this mission
don't die I can't kill the fish I'd kill
her don't die
oh now he's dead and he smells like fish
can you stop shooting me attacked by
Fish Head hilarious at X-Men yep I need
to find Good Times
he swung at me and he hit a bottle of
rum here and he set himself on fire this
game is so fun you guys why how do you
think of the possibilities you could
throw fish heads you could throw arms
you could throw heads at their friends
just freak them all out jump up from
above take them out explode them with
whale oil tanks there's so many kill
themselves apparently yeah
I've lost a fish head I'm sorry can you
eat that fish no I don't want to
remember yeah no we don't want to eat
that fish they were asking if you could
eat it from the figs where's the kitchen
right kitchen's back here
oh goodness I think I might have
murdered everyone oh
wait what did they do oh yeah just just
put her to sleep this guy doesn't care
at all no he literally does not even
bothered I can't be bothered
I feel bad for those fish though xh-128
says is this live stream going up on the
channel as a vid yes go back to our
YouTube
and check it out after the fact this
whole stream
that our friends at Bethesda brought us
is coming back on to YouTube's
after the fact you can see the full
two-hour stream get in the water
get in the tub
I'm guessing that yeah they're dead now
Billy said I love you and Dave we love
you too hearts
the fishtail go that's what I want now
I don't even know what they're cooking
there we go tail oh look at that tail
all right let's jump in the sea it's
only right chat wants you to jump in the
sea jump in the sea with that fishtail
only feels only right where is the
optimal spot to jump into the sea
highest point maybe that thing no
no off the tower Maybe
off of the Tower and jump into the sea
right
Toby oh
sick roll though doesn't even care does
not even care not even phased by it
yeah you're not the only one that could
throw stuff Omer can said go insane and
rage
in real life
both I've lost a fishtail right if you
want me to go in the sea I'll go in the
sea we have five minutes left they want
you to jump Mizuki said we have five
minutes go and jump
the highest point over here Godly
Destroyer also wants us to jump why is
it with you guys and jumping in the sea
they just want to see what happens when
we jump in the sea I'm assuming you're
gonna die I think so I guess
unless we're a really good diver
I mean you can't swim but this might be
here we go
oh
that's all the way he does we died we
did it for you that was all for you guys
it's because there's those weird giant
fish in the sea yep I thought the cooks
are chopping up
but we're almost at the we can can you
end this in four minutes yes Mission
yeah yeah assuming the checkpoint was
merciful yeah let's yeah we did the the
merciful
got the doctor back yeah Miss Wendy yeah
I can kill everybody yeah no killed a
lot of people yeah we mixed it up we did
lethal we did some stealth in this
mission to show you a little bit of a
balance of the gameplay of little both
Lila both so we have to run now four
minutes to finish this Mission and then
we are finishing up our Dishonored 2
live stream brought To Us by our buddies
at Bethesda it's gonna be a speed run
this is the PS4 version that you're
looking at we are finishing up this
Mission as corvo mixing it up with a
little bit of stealth a little bit of
lethal
closer than I was
you can get your last shout outs in on
Twitch and YouTube
holler at you girl
and also Dave holler at Dave as well
holla at you boy Dave
it's my Mantra m50616 said this game
doesn't teach you how to swim there is a
quick you have to choose to let it teach
you yeah there is it's towards the
beginning of the game yeah there is
swimming
but usually not from such a far drop
but it does teach you how to swim and
you can swim fast as well you don't have
to swim slowly
Kobe
boom
I think is everyone dead okay we can
have a level then
idrisa said can you shout out shout outs
to adressa
should I
I turned it off did I accidentally put
the oil back in did you
maybe it didn't save maybe someone
replaced it they're like oh no why is
this off and they went and replaced it
bring it back
I did look I did it again wow
there it is stupid machine
last chance to get your shout outs on
YouTube and twitch how did you die I
didn't die
Megan Foster died oh wait thank you so
if they kill Megan I think it's game
over so make sure that you get the
mission done in time and that Megan
doesn't die oh we finished the mission
once at least yes I've got time to run
there again two minutes left in the
Stream it's gonna be kind of close
cutting it close but we will finish this
Mission and then we will cut our Stream
So I think happened is I turned the uh
Watchtower off and she was like cool the
watchtower's off I better go pick up
Corva oh yeah pick up kova it's like
okay good to go and then someone took
her out
all right Speed Run mode
gotta go fast
we didn't mean to kill Megan sorry
Mizuki I didn't kill her no the
Watchtower the Watchtower killed her
that's the story and I'm sticking to it
Caleb said how do you slide upstairs do
you want to do it
can you can you do it
don't need no physics physics not a
problem we can slide up them stairs
liar to send him out
hello to our buddies on YouTube xh128
and godly destroyer197 thanks for all
those questions today so there's your
shout out there you go Buddies
don't put the thing back in the thing
this time
we have one minute left in the Stream
but we will finish this mission for you
are we pretty close oh yeah okay then
we'll let this run a couple minutes over
Megan just we'll just wait till the
stream ends and then we will conclude
our stream we'll wait till this Mission
ends and we'll conclude our stream for
you all right get that away get it away
[Music]
haha
all right all right Megan I'm ready to
go
take me back to the boat
here she comes she has no idea what just
happened I didn't bring my head this
time though
everyone's Dead all right let's go
lusitanium said the Brits are in the USA
I see yep he flew all the way over here
to hang out with me and play some
Dishonored too
it's a good time let's go yeah
yeah Kells to the yeah yeah we did it
this place is full of bugs nice job all
right we finished that mission thank you
so much for joining us so I'm Chastity
you can follow me on Twitter Chastity
underscore V Dave over here I'm at your
regular day yeah thanks for checking out
Dishonored 2 brought To Us by our
friends at Bethesda you can play the
game on ps4 PC or Xbox One today go get
it it's a lot of fun and if you missed
any of this watch the whole live stream
again it's going to be up on our YouTube
thanks for joining us and we will see
you next time
[Music]
the Duke's ground inventor
absolutely brilliant
another genius just what we needed